et pour un clip j'ai une belle vie des
abeilles à quoi devrait on va leur
montrer les arts doses dans la saison 2
de valider série disponible sur la
plateforme mike annales les arts dos ce
sont les jumeaux du rap français deux
jeunes de 21 ans originaire de mantes la
jolie ils ont déjà plusieurs titres à
leur actif
[Musique]
les guitares sont les perdants et qui
connaît pas les jumeaux du rapport
[Musique]
ryanair a ou vivent dans le quartier du
val fourré à gutenberg dans leur musique
ils racontent leur quotidien en 2018 ici
avec le label wati b cette signature
leur tremplin pour aller chercher plus
haut on est des personnes dans l'excès
nous quand on veut quelque chose on se
dit pas je vais tout faire pour l'avoir
et je vais la voir je vais l'avoir dont
vous nous motiver on a eu à tirer mais
on veut pas que wati b vous aussi percé
on veut devenir des meilleurs les argos
font leurs débuts ici dans le centre
culturel les ateliers chopin à mantes la
jolie à l'âge de 13 ans ils viennent de
lancer leur premier flot et prennent des
cours avec mr mam professeur de musique
au sein de la structure c'est une fierté
franchement je change pas brogard
à leur égard et on a toujours la même
relation même malgré qu'ils soient à la
qui disait de la notoriété qui font des
choses très intéressantes moi c'est une
fierté déjà que les jeunes qui sont
sortis d'ici puissent faire ce genre de
choses fan de musique les arts de son
plusieurs influences il écoute de tout
mais le rap américain et français est
dominant même si la musique reste la
priorité ils ont une activité
professionnelle en parallèle ça nous
ouvre plus l'esprit on aura plus de
choses à raconter dans nos musiques etc
mais il faut savoir que on a toujours la
même détermination pour la musique dans
l'opulence r on est encore en
développement c'est encore du charbon on
travaille on travaille c'est en studio
on enchaîne les clips on enchaîne des
projets des mixtapes pourquoi pas
l'album ce premier album devrait
s'intituler les jumeaux du rap français
en attendant une série de freestyle est
en cours de production un clin d'oeil à
leur apparition dans la série validé
pas changé pour mathieu 6-4 son grand
écran cependant sa lancée